so my again my name is Vasily I'm
working in Yandex just for you
information Yandex is a Russian IT
company
okay so Yandex is a national company and
it's not just some IT company in Russia
it's today one of the biggest IT company
- and it's a his biggest search engine
in the world and quite successful
because we have used for many years
machining techniques off our production
problems especially we have quite big
experience with Vijay and Whiston and
two years ago we've released an
open-source CAD boost I am the main
developer or GP Russian of calvo's and
today I will talk about watch this
library about how we work with
categorical and text data and we will
provide you some overview so here on the
slide a very brief span structure of my
talk firstly I will explain for everyone
which vision boostin is about maybe
someone doesn't know then I will explain
how we deal this categorical and check
data in an automatic way it's our it's
something that you will not find in
other bucyk libraries like it's a boost
or light GBM and finally I will give you
a brief overview of functionality what
performance you can expect watch our he
just be fair and so on so let's start
our talk today and I wanted to start by
clinical
what is beautiful about the end boosting
is technique as well as can boost is a
mutation of the technique that designed
to solve supervised learning problems
here on the slide you can see a very
rough illustration of what supervised
doing consists of in applied problems
firstly we have some applications like
medicine finance or search engine and so
on for this application we have some
data at hand this data could be for
example music images it could be
something classic like numerical data
and so on and with this data set we want
to solve our problem
but this we have some tools like linear
models neural networks and so on data at
hand is usually just number of samples
and for each sample we have some label
we need to predict this label based on a
sample alone and for different
applications if you have two predictor
this label in some of John way this
optimal way is usually specified by
application curve example sometimes he
wants to solve classification problem
and this option way example could be
image to optimize a symmetric or
rhythmic loss or cross interfere or
something like this or we need to solve
regression problem so this is mean
square error and usually different type
of tools like linear models like
incidentally it could be easily used for
different type of problems just select
the proper loss function and that's it
but for different type of input data we
need to use different type of tools
example I think everyone knows that
today if you need to make a classifier
for images you definitely should use the
values on neural networks and for
example for audio for speech recognition
it's probably a convolutional neural
networks or some recurrent neural
networks and here on the slide one way
to classify the data we have today in
our apply problems firstly we have
so-called unstructured data it's raw
data light musical images and this is
place where you need to use neural
networks they will provide you the
state-of-the-art result but there is one
more type of input data that we use in
practice it's a classical type of data
it's table of data usually we present
this data a semantics where each row of
this matrix is sample and each column is
a feature or a projector that was
designed by people using their own mind
and maybe some newer networks or
automatic techniques in such way that
this which will provide us some
information about the problem you solve
it will help us to predict life and for
such type of input data a
state-of-the-art results are cheap not
by deep link no neural networks here we
have gradient boosting con decision
trees technique this technique achieves
state of results and basically a do this
technique builds very simple model it's
a linear combination of decision trees
you start just train one you shouldn't
dream then generatively
in a greedy manner we train one more
tree in such way that this tree will
correct the errors of previous ones
there is mud everyone who is interested
what you want don't want to spend time
but on this we I wish to cover more
high-level aspects of everything so look
for literature for more details if you
don't know about greedy acoustic what's
important that will gain wisdom we have
several nice properties mostly this
technique would be oak well for very
small datasets unlike for example neural
networks if you have 1000 samples 10,000
samples no problem giant will work and
at the same time this technique could be
scaled for very big datasets for example
in Yandex via a training radiant wisdom
on several almost on terabytes of data
and secondly this technique is very easy
to use ingredient because there are all
things that I need to be carefully
change its depth of each decision tree
you know model its number of decision
trees and it's a learning rate just
these three parameters and almost all
other effort you could spend on this
data this will give you more benefits
than dealing with the model unlike for
example neural networks where you can
spend months or years searching for
which are accept but it's when you solve
practical problems not when you want you
to be competition for example on cattle
competition you need to know everything
but it's not real world it's more like
the competition so when no competitions
spend time waiting this day to not try
to work with your model at least for 90%
of time
okay so this technique is quite popular
and for example Oh Oh God almost all
cattle competitions are won by some type
of wisdom tyranny and today we have
several efficient implementation of this
technique its energy boost its car boost
and it's light GBM no no no I will talk
definitely about canvas I will much talk
about eg boost or labium well but I
think all these three libraries are very
great open source contributions and
provided well data scientists a lot to
deal with a lot of possibility to solve
their problems and that boost is a media
boost in addition to a library that was
so developed but from our expertise
using Prezi and boosting in our
practical tasks we've been using region
within 4 years for example in 20 and 12
if already have GPU version 4 in 20
until there was no deplane could ever
know exists but we've already change all
those on GPU and two years ago we've
released in open source our latest
version of indian goostin it's cat
booster now we quite popular already
have for most 4000 starts and one thing
that we have and all other libraries
does but doesn't provide you is a
ability to work is non numerical data
like categorical and now it's also
checks date and next the next couple of
slides I will explain the basic idea how
to deal with non numerical data the
batch is we think we it could be used
with other boosting libraries as well
but for most we have tightly integrated
this idea and gradient boosting
calgary's so it provides slightly better
results so let's start firstly several
roads about decision trees en boosting
is very powerful technique but this
technique has one limitation
input features input data should be
efficiently handled by decision tree my
eye isn't held I mean that we should be
able to learn decision tree and then
this decision tree should generalize
well so we could use it on some
dependent but the agent said and have
which mietek or device this model with
just over hit all did very well-known a
Pyrrhic effect is that decision tree
work best with numerical features to let
you have some nature of all generation
for example here rating and so on when
we could take two radius and compare
them for other type of data now some
approaches that allows us to train
decision trees but they are not used
widely because they won't provide you
very good results because of this before
in Houston we have something like you
can see here on a slide it's basic
pipeline how we solve practical problems
with gradient boosting you Astley we
have data this could be Jax date music
data something some walks from your
service and so on and based on this data
we perform each extraction and each
engineering one what part of this peach
extraction feature generic could be
learning the deployment model so it
today talk about boosting you should not
think that boosting and declaring our
competitors nothing at all you could
efficiently combine them the only thing
is you should firstly preprocessor data
convert it to matrix with numerical
pitches service features business or
just some order relation and then you
could train Committee on boosting and
ship model for production for example
and here the most time-consuming step is
feature extraction and peach engine if
you closely look at this step only you
can see that there are two types of
features that are usually developed some
are which that are domain specific
example it could be some feature that is
specially developed for search engine
example page around from Google or it
could be some feature for medicine and
so on and this features can be computed
automatically for different type of
problems
but there is some other type of [ __ ]
that are basically let's take some data
perform some automatic algorithm oh and
J we will have some number that could be
efficiently used in boosting and this
will not require you some
domain-specific knowledge
interestingly for some type of data you
could make automatic feature engineering
based on stage some state-of-the-art
approaches that I use for example on K
go and in caboose
we've implemented special techniques to
deal with categorical data and with Jax
data and I will start by explaining why
we do this categorical data so
categorical features features that are
not directly comparable with each other
example it could be a hash tags music
Jenner and so on and for such type of
features it's very well known that there
is this technique called one hot and
code amongst that could be used and its
technique very simple just for each
category introduce one new column is set
the value to one if we if this
categorical which is a go-to category
from this column or there otherwise but
this technique has limitations
this technique can't be aqueous features
with big personality
for example with fresh text or there is
categorical feature user idea and we
have millions of user IDs what's more
sometimes with train model then there is
a new user and we need to retain
everything from scratch what column will
not work in such scenario what still can
boost could do it automatically much to
deal with categorical features
miscarriage analogy we need something
more specific for high cardinality
features and it turns out that we could
compute special statistics based on
category and this statistic could be
very powerful features we can boast we
have two types of statistics first we
could compute statistic based just on
category itself here on the slide an
example I
Roberto feature and basically a
statistic based on category is
probability that this category the that
we will see this category in our date so
we have some category like lose we can
pitch number of sample this bluest label
and use this instead of those this is
the medical picture has natural order
relation and turns out could be quite
good but it's not the most efficient way
to deal with categorical data because
such type of features do not use
information about problem we are so we
have labels and it's very desirable to
incorporate this information in our
model in our and there is special
technique called label encoding
sometimes it allows to efficiently
combine categorical features and
information from categorical gate and or
from label and make one numerical
feature from this this this technique is
simpler to explain no classification
tasks so for the rest of my talk I will
assume that we are southern
classification problem but for
recreation for rank it still could be
generalized and discussion problem and
leg labeling cuz it simply takes a
category of this category we have we
have some true success rate that our
label will be equal to one
it's just some probability you just we
don't know it but if we know it then we
could use it as a medical feature and it
would be very powerful predictor but you
can't know it at least while we will
have fine amount of data so like in any
statistical tasks we just make some
estimator of this statistic you could
use maximum good estimator but this
estimator has limitations for example
here on the slide again categorical
features rather and but very often for
each category we have just several
observations like for example here for
blues
you have just one thumb up it's a label
one and nothing else if we will use
maximum Quixote estimator then we will
predict one for each sample it looks
like wet feature there it is
another type of estimators to buy Asian
ones and they could be quite good
especially if you could find a good
prior but still they will be one big
conceptual problem when we have our data
you usually want to make we want to make
a label encoding on this data and then
we want to chain very powerful technique
greedy algorithm on the same data set
using the same labels when we perform
label in content so they replace
category with some estimator of virility
we basically take label and join it in
our features no way that we will not
repeat there is one solution we could
just split the data take one part of
data to perform labor encoding the
second part of data to train our model
but we will lose the nature it's not
good and should they exist one trick
which allows two trained to perform
label encoding and to train the DM
boosting
on the same data and avoid this target
leakage so we will not over fit basic
idea is here on the slide let's assume
that for each sample we have some
timestamp it could be a real time step
from real data or it could be just some
random variable after we have this
timestamp we could sort all our
observations by this time stamp and then
let's assume we want to perform label
and project for example each time tip at
this time we will not use all our data
to perform estimation but we will use
samples from time 0 to time t minus 1
for example here we have I think time 3
ladies does so village to the pub level
recording for this little ambience F of
0
- and don't mumble I'm stop ever come
down and used only this data to perform
estimation of success rate it could not
shown that theoretically and this will
average target leakage and it's proved
to be work very well in practice okay Oh
finally one last thing about categorical
gate and chemists statistics that I've
described from previous slides
definitely could be committed not only
for a single feature but we could also
compute them for combination of hitches
as well for example let's assume we need
to predict if the user will like a song
he listened so much and we have features
we have features on and we have a user
ID combinations of these two features
could be very strong predictor for the
task while just simple rather ill not so
we've wanted to use feature combinations
in our model but one problem we don't
want to have the my knowledge we don't
know which which combinations I punched
we need to perform this after multiply
and number of different feature
combinations is an exponentially big so
country compute them all in translation
stage in compost we have special
algorithm ah it's a greedy algorithm
that search for this speech relations on
the fly during decision tree learning
its reputation quite expensive because
of this caboose could sometimes works
very slow on native is big number of
categorical he just but turns out that
this approach to search for feature
combinations could be very efficient on
publicly available to assets miss
categorical features when we released
our boost in open source we make a
comparison of our library and other
boosting libraries on the de sets with
categorical features or for
classification problem and here on the
slide are results compared algorithmic
loss it's one that each library was
optimizing and as you can see a boost
performance all other libraries in terms
of quality
okay it's all this is all about
categorical data if you want something
more I will give you links about it
after my talk now let's talk about text
data this autumn we released initial
support for text data in can boost and
idea to deal with text is essentially
the same one we used for categorical
fees again we have some data input now
this data is text and we need to convert
this text to a numerical feature in some
automatic way how we could do it just we
could use a well-known technique back of
words let's just for each word in a some
dictionary make a column and set it to
one if this word was text and zero
otherwise very simple technique very
powerful but if this technique will be
done carefully and cut will do it
automatically and this technique again
has the same limitations that you will
see when you do one hot encoding because
number of words is very big sometimes
you can't just yawn
example of decision tree on pictures
from back of words but still if you will
look this this technique where foliage
good well
secondly we could use something like we
do if used for categorical features with
Bible encoded label encoding basically
it says that you have some categorical
feature this for each category we
perform some classifier octavarium
feature this is very simple classifier
we just use constant as our decision for
checks data we can't use label encoding
because each text is unique but we could
try to use some light text pacifier
based on this text and then if this
crucify will be a fast enough that we
could learn each in online manner like
we used the trick this time for
categorical features then
could train discus fire on our jet in
online manner
make probability project probabilities
the projections of a label for each
texture and use these probabilities as
inputs for our division boosting and
train on the same later gravity and
boost current decision tree without any
target leakage when can boost we have
support for different type conspires
much the most and we experimented with
several types but for now we decided to
use basically a naive Bayesian
classifier because it's quite simple it
could we computed in one pass through
the data and it provide you create a
good results so this functionality is a
it was released I think one months ago
we are still working on more things like
for example making linear regression as
classifier or something else and we have
a kept on agent we need to work with
embedding Strom neural networks it is
the same idea it's even we have it in
our code base but we just don't have
interfaces for Python still but you can
already use it but with one hand
imitation sadly but this technique for
now is available only on GBA version of
our library for speed version we will
edit I think in a couple of months Kim
so I think that's each about Jillian is
data and now the last part of my talk
will be about brief overview of our
library watch each have four watch
performances and expect and so on and
firstly the this technique about data
that I've talked about this techniques
that from the best of my knowledge
available only in turn boost so if you
need them you you will need to try
calmest but if you still you don't need
them you can still use calvo's because
it's classical to be a button that could
efficiently deal this category with
numerical features as well
we have too many features to describe
them all here on the slide just some
examples I think I don't need to say
that but it's it could be installed very
easily like any root wisdom fiber just
type pipe and stop and everything will
work we know that we are not the only
boosting library in the world know that
someone some could be familiar with
slide GBM someone could be familiar with
EXA boost so we provide you I believe
synonyms for their parameters so if you
need to speech it will be pretty easy
okay about data about data presentation
is you are trying to optimize everything
we could so if you have example mission
values it's not problem we will form we
will deal with them after magical the
next thing in composed we have many
different objectives so if you need to
solve the spatial problem around a
problem education problem for example
Poisson regression or mean absolute
elation except and definitely least
square regression you have was function
that worked out of box and you don't
need to implement them the next thing
when you do this GN boost incur you
usually want to compute matrix and check
matrix during training and you want to
do it on some independent validation set
usually we train model this some
imported metric like a look at this
metric on a validation set when our
model starts overfitting
you just stop our training and shrink
model to this stress in that was to be
implemented many different metrics for
classification or regression for ranking
and could compute them automatically
during training and exploit them in the
picture for example or internal board
and one more thing we could compute this
matrix not only on a CPU if you are
change on GPU then we could compute them
on each period as well for example a
symmetric is very expensive and
if you can't compute them on GPU when
you trained on GPU will spend all your
time computers metric instant of game
one next piece off feature is a feature
detector we could compute this matrix
and also you could automatically decide
that you start over feature that you
don't need to train more so we don't
stop automatically and you don't don't
need to set iterations for very big
member and look at what to not waste
your computation resource okay now the
next thing is model analysis any
machining model should be analyzed we
need to understand why features why and
what features are important what sample
size and and why model makes prediction
in that most we meant very powerful
analytical tool kit we have some classic
types of each importance measures one
could find for example in elements of
statistical game
because some people it smells that I
designed for racket tasks classic
approaches will much go for them and
also we've updated several techniques
that we have proposed on recent
Machinarium conferences on top machine
conferences like no it's 2017 your shape
values its each importance measure that
could be computed for each sample we
have some document we could compute for
in theoretically optimal way importance
of each feature for this document we
have support for influential samples
from
ICML change 18 paper and this allows you
to find what observations I bought it
for yamato what influence
model predictions and finally we have a
mana forest toolkit it's a new paper
that will be published in your lips
change my team that gives one more new
way to look at decision trees hey that's
part of my talk it will be about
performance we have some functionality
but if you you'll need one year but
training a model I think you do not just
like real job because time is a budget
and caboose is highly efficient why bruh
here we have a highly optimized
speargun and here is a proof you compare
our speakers on these our competitors
obvious ledge BM this exhaust and as you
can see that booster sometimes faster
sometimes slower but there is there is
no big difference we can say that they
are comparable that you could use any of
this library to solve your problem there
would be no not one months we see a one
year example but this our superiors and
one moment I there is dataset is
something I million samples we 11
million samples for someone you can
think that these are big datasets from
my perspective for this are very small
data sets that could be handled by this
machine for example and in practice we
need to deal with much bigger data at
least sometimes and for very big
datasets we don't want to use CPUs we
have very powerful GPUs today like
Nvidia try we 100 more Titan we let
advise you very great benefits compared
to CPU for example here on the slide we
have a chart and we computed related
speed-up of our GPL version compared to
our superior version and may be used for
several modern GPUs compared to 56
logical CPU as you can see the more data
we have there are more benefits you have
from GPS and when you need to train on
several millions of supports we've
several hundred features Nvidia Titan it
could be or Nvidia v1
it could be almost 40 times faster than
pretty powerful CPU and it's - for our
GP version and algebra was not only
faster than our superiors but it's also
they'll be faster than our competitors
we allege BM and exhibit also have
superior versions but as you can see
from the slide on the same diff sets
kamusta
always fast ok last think about
performance it was about training time
but after we trained we wanted to use
this model to predict some of our users
and Egyptian times for some applications
matter the most
we have C++ implementation of
interference with SSE optimizations and
what's more in CAD most of you have
special type of decision trees I don't
want to talk in details about it but
this type of decision trees allows us to
make influence significant and classical
type of decision trees and at the same
time have the same quality as a result
can boost could perform more projects on
CPU I think 50 times faster than it was
supposed or light beer
it will depend on dataset and number of
T's but 20 to 50 times faster I think he
you will obtain and if this is not
enough we have GPIO inference that will
be even faster
ok so wrapping up today I've talked
about can boost its giant boost and
decision tree library we have state of
the art approach to deal with
categorical pitches we could work with
text but even a GPO for today we have
high performance implementation on spew
on GPU and we could solve
latency critical tasks when you need
projections and finally we have four
very easy to use analytical and
visualization toolkit
if you interested you want more
information
firstly you couldn't read our papers it
says more about what it's secondly if
you want more about boosting just look
at Wikipedia for example or in some
classical book with wisdom and if you
wanted to know how to use our Lyerly how
to use it from peyten you could go for
our website we have documentation or in
our github thank you for your attention
I feel free to ask any questions I don't
know I think someone should give
microphones questions on the nice talk
by the way thank you so for the
vectorization of text you mentioned
using knife baits yes right I wasn't
clear I mean knife bees would give you
one result right it's one class right
was one data point basically for
document how do you actually create a
vector from it if you solve binary
classification that's not your problem
I'm sorry maybe biasion is we could use
narration for binary classification
problem
we just need to probability that the
class will be a go to one and this is a
feature when we deal with multi
classification there will be if you have
[ __ ] classes so there will be car - one
probabilities watch it could be easily
generalized for Mucha pacification and
indeed this can be easily generalized
for regression problem but it's we are
designed to deal this specification can
you use the document embedding as a
feature
firstly first thinker emergence from
neural networks is our very best
features for negligent boosting but
something like course no similar to for
example beech tree and document abated
and
in case of search engine the query
embedded could be very powerful Egypt
and we are using it internally but we
have plans to edit to can post very some
code you know code base for is impedance
already but as I said you don't have
interfaces to Python and I think we will
add them in near future
we have a slide beta for them auto
performance in terms of prediction power
so I just want to see how by using their
cat boos Kappas everything is better
outperform than using other prediction
algorithms I just want to see the
comparison chart of the performance of
the prediction not about the time I
understand the time in terms of time so
very efficient this prediction power yes
and for numerical data we will be
comparable because for example for GPU
version we have one type of decision
test pass we have support to train all
most likely was very similar to ones
from IBM or from extra post right let's
thank Vasily once more
[Applause]